welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and the Mandalorian Finally
Revealed how grogu escaped the Jedi
Temple on the night of Order 66 Jedi
Master Keller and Beck but major chunks
of grogu's timeline remain a mystery
including where grogu went from here and
what his Destiny will be Beyond this
time period is the Mandalorian actually
restoring balance to the sequel ERA with
a new Hero wisened by the failures of
the cult orthodoxies of the Jedi and the
mandalorians I'm gonna break it all down
and subscribe to our new channel did he
dive where our next film analysis will
be Christopher Nolan's Interstellar
chapter 20 of the Mandalorian included
grogu's flashback to order 66 last seen
for a brief moment while grogu was with
Luke Skywalker in chapter 6 of The Book
of Boba Fett let me help you remember
and the most uncomfortable looking good
boy pet ever transitions into a
triggering blocked out for a reason
memory of that one time this guy's dad
killed all his teachers and his
classmates interesting how both grogu's
training with Luke and his mentorship
from the armorer in Japan 20 of the
Mandalorian brought grogu back to this
specific memory and both Luke and the
armor are consider it essential to their
tutelage to open up Old Wounds like this
it's almost as if learning how both
these schools of thought suck is
essential to grogu's character
development but this recent episode of
the Mandalorian shows grogu moments
after that flashback to the residential
part of the Jedi Temple shown in book of
Boba Fett but that moment ended with 500
first clone troopers charging forward
toward grogu after taking out a handful
of his protectors when we picked back up
with grogu in the Mandalorian he
suddenly has four New Jedi protecting
him in a different part of the Jedi
Temple so there remains a mystery Gap
period where custody of grogu may have
briefly passed to those clone troopers
before four New Jedi arrived and Greg
who's bassinet was just kind of fumbled
back in the Jedi possession but these
four Jedi know about master kelleran and
they know to take grogu into that
elevator where Keller and back is
waiting for him on level six he's played
by Ahmed best then never appreciated
enough actor behind Jar Jar Binks and
after a brief Chase Kellerman takes
grogu to a ship a Naboo h-type Nubian
yacht with Senate guards dressed as
Naboo Palace security I explained the
breakdown that there is a very good
chance that this was set up by Senator
Jar Jar Binks which could also be fueled
by that Ahmed best connection there the
Senate Guard Captain s kelleran what
about the others and Keller and grimly
responds there are no others telling us
that there might have been other secret
VIP Jedi kids that kelleran was tasked
with rescuing or maybe it's just
kelleran's mission to rescue all the
Younglings and Master Skywalker got to
the others first Kellerman may have been
the first one to find their bodies both
the kids that Anakin slaughtered in
Revenge of the Sith and Rivas group that
was shown in the Obi-Wan Kenobi series
but where did kelleran take grogu from
here we don't yet know but Naboo would
be a very dangerous destination for
grogu as the home planet of Emperor
Palpatine I've speculated that kelleran
and grogu could be the founders of the
path the underground railroad system of
evacuating Jedi refugees shown in the
Obi-Wan Kenobi series a network that we
know Quinlan Voss was a part of so
sometime between Order 66 that was in 19
BBY and the start of the Mandalorian
series that's 9 ABY five years after
Return of the Jedi it would be a span of
28 years sometime during this grogu left
the possession of Keller and back and
ended up in the hands of that Nikko gang
those are the ones guarding grogu
windinjara and ig-11 found him in the
Mandalorian pilot episode and grogu in
that moment is in the same bassinet that
he left the Jedi Temple in in this
recent Mandalorian episode it just
gained a lot of scuff marks and grime
over the years so presumably for most of
that 28 year span grogu was under the
protection of Keller and Beck or some
other Jedi or someone else friendly to
the Jedi and just managed to avoid
detection by inquisitors and only
recently battle the hands of those
nictos who must have known at least a
bit how valuable this cargo was now for
the first two seasons of the Mandalorian
grogu accompanied dinar and as he
attempted to keep him away from off
Gideon and buff Gideon's plot to use
grogu's midichlorian Rich DNA to
genetically engineer strain casts
presumably for Palpatine's secret
cloning operation but at the end of
season 2 din Jaron handed off grogu to
Luke Skywalker so the child could be
trained as a Jedi training that we saw
in chapter 6 of The Book of Boba Fett
and here we saw the origin of Luke's
first school an institution that would
later become what Young Ben solo was a
part of before Ben turned on his Uncle
Luke and joined snoke to become kylo Ren
but just to clear up some timeline
questions here right before season three
premiere John Favre told the sky talkers
show that grogu and then Jordan had
spent quote many years together and that
grobu spent two years with Luke
Skywalker training on that planet and
then we know that he's been rescued and
spent many years with the Mandalorian
went back with with Luke now we've been
two years apart from him there training
and some of us were very confused for a
day because did Mando really spend two
years butchering butchers with the
darksaber before only then going to the
armor to tell her about grogu on that
ring world then thankfully variety got a
bit of clarification from Fabro because
you said that
grogu was with Luke Skywalker for many
years uh I I don't know if I said many
years it's about it's probably about the
real time that that we've experienced it
so it was too it was the end of season
two when they say goodbye we checked in
the book of Boba Fett about a year ago
when they party company again and then
he rejoined the Mandalorian so now I
think somewhere in there somewhere uh
more than one and less than you know
somewhere between one and two uh zero in
two years so not that many years no no
no no
that many so dude screen time we know we
only have 30 years to tell all our
stories we have a lot more stories to
tell that that do help that bro but it
does tell us that these creators don't
really have a memorized grasp of the
in-universe timeline and you know what
that's okay now sometimes when you love
a TV series or a movie it's not enough
to just have been watching it you need
some merch to commemorate the occasion
and nerd riots got you covered if the
finale of The Last of Us left you hungry
for more pick up a lunch of us tea
available in cream or black featuring
the logo of Todd's Steakhouse or episode
8 of the series donate there though just
don't do that unless you're a cannibal
in which case Bon Appetit if you're
stoked for the upcoming John Wick movie
nerd Riot has a whole line of John
Wick's shirts to make you feel like
you've got a seat at the high table
there's
the gun Chuck's tea and a t for the high
table itself proclaiming I have served I
will be of service get them now and
you'll be able to wear them to opening
nights and then also the next weekend
when you see John Wick chapter four for
the second time and of course if you're
obsessing over the Mandalorian right now
there's a whole line of Mando merch in
the way collection with teas beanies
hats and even stuff for kids to get your
hands on the merch you need head to nerd
riot.shop today join the riot over at
nerdriot.shop but essentially if
Mandalorian began in 9 ABY and each
season has been about a year of time
including the book of Boba Fett we would
be at about 12 to 13 ABY now which would
put the force awakens which is set in 34
Avi only 21 or 22 years from now Favre
says they only have 30 years to tell
their stories and I am not about to hold
this guy to any numerical certainty when
it comes to timeline but I do think
there is room here to explore grogu
after the events of the sequel Trilogy a
storyline just completely removed from
the Skywalker Saga taking place after
the rise of Skywalker we're so concerned
about Goku's fate within the series of
the Mandalorian that we forget that it
might actually be the origin story of
the next great adult hero of the Star
Wars franchise because with the fan base
mix from the sequel Trilogy lucasfilm
has yet to announce any future Star Wars
film it's been so long this new
generation of films they're hoping for
from Rey and Finn and Poe and Janna bb-8
they definitely seem to be waiting to
pull the trigger in any story set after
the rise of Skywalker and I think one
reason for that could be they are
waiting for the Mandalorian to finish
telling this era of the child's life or
at least to get to a place in this
series where each episode isn't overly
concerned with grogu's survival so that
after the rise of Skywalker 30 years
from now they can introduce a slightly
older grogu who would be in his 80s at
this point not yet an old man maybe not
even talking yet but someone in his late
adolescent years we know Master Yoda
around the time he turned 100 became a
Jedi master so this would be a critical
passage into adulthood for grogu and
that could be an interesting time to see
him as a front man of a new era of Star
Wars characters so if that is a
Direction they could go with grogu let's
again look back at where he is now
thematically the Mandalorian series
seems to be setting up grogu as the
first combined Jedi and Mandalorian
since tarvisla someone armored in
Bhaskar who also wields the darksaber
but really grogu seems to be rejecting
both of these ideologies he could be
transitioning into someone wise enough
to see the error in both the way and the
code he witnessed firsthand the failure
of the Jedi Order and when Luke
Skywalker gave him the choice to follow
in Yoda's footsteps with Yoda's
lightsaber grogu rejected it and now
he's being trained as a Mandalorian
foundling he does not want to play rough
with the other kids he wants to just sit
by the beach and play with his crabs I
think this kid is destined to reject
this Colts Orthodoxy too so what does
grogu want well based off of the little
things we've seen from him on this show
he definitely has a connection with
nature pretty much every animal he comes
across he has a kind of spiritual
connection with and that's really what I
want the most from grogu a more
meditative approach to the force closer
to Luke's naturalistic teachings in The
Last Jedi I want to learn more about the
force not the way it was codified in
textbooks but the true nature of it we
are long overdue for a trip back to the
cosmic realm of mortis with the Father
the Son of the daughter and that Clone
Wars mortise Arc we could pick back up
with that removed Matt Smith subplot
from the rise of Skywalker that many of
us believe was connected with the Sun
but it was a pretty groovy thing it
looked like it was really groovy Pawn
concept it's pretty big it was a big
thing yeah it was like a big story
detail you know transformative Star Wars
story detail but they know it never
quite got over the line you know it was
a big rare shift in the in the history
of the franchise just imagine it a young
adult grogu neither Jedi nor Mandalorian
but with the best parts of both
branching away from the Skywalker Saga
teamed up was someone a bit chattier
maybe but on an archaeological Raiders
of the Lost Ark style Relic hunt that
incurs the Wrath of the Gods of the Star
Wars universe that would be a Luke film
Adventure I'd sign up for but I want to
know for me what Star Wars movie do you
think deserves to be the next big title
and can grogu carry this franchise
reminder to subscribe to our new channel
the Deep dive and it can support us by
grabbing some merch at nerd riot.shop
follow me on Instagram and Twitter at
eavos follow me rockstars And subscribe
to new rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]